I could tell you about sadun and the
tall those were always your favorites I
have to do this I have to do a
prequel um so I started thinking about
my history and what would be a good area
to write it and I came up with the the
Duncan egg stuff I was particularly
attracted uh that whole story is built
around a tournament and I love medieval
tournaments and reading about them
writing about them there there's of
course some of them in the main the main
books uh but this this was an
opportunity in a time of Peace not war
to look at a medieval tournament with
all its pageantry and the jousting and
the combat and reveal a little of of
West rosi history so this is the famous
book of Brothers all the great Deeds of
all the great Kings go so Duncan the
tour four pages for S Duncan he must
have been quite a man so they say for
free you can now listen to the entire
audio book Fire and Blood On which house
of the Dragon is based and which covers
the entire targaryan history including
current and future events of House of
the Dragon for free with a notable trial
using our Link in the description all
boys dream of becoming Knights the boys
with Talent dream of becoming King's God
the boys without Talent well I wouldn't
know for centuries the king's Scot had
been the glory of the realm Aon the
Conqueror had his established the order
as his personal Guardians after uniting
Westeros with Fire and Blood he knew
that some of his subjects wouldn't take
to Conquest and his dragons were no use
against knives in the dark no doubt
surrounding himself with the greatest
knights in Westerose made his rule more
palatable and less foreign as
well everyone in his kingdom soon knew
the names and sung the songs of the
king's Godot I suddenly did from
earliest days we protected the king and
his family we killed his enemies and let
his arm armies we gave him counsel when
asked and kept his Secrets when not we
swore to hold no lands take no wives and
father no children like the Nights Watch
except with a real job to do was I AED
to see my name inscribed in the same
book as my heroes of course not I was 16
and
Brilliant I knew it belonged there
beside the name of s Duncan the tall Who
as a hedge Knight broke several of
Prince Aran taran's teeth while
defending Ador woman he later Rose to
Lord command and burned beside his King
at Sumer hall because sir Duncan had
sworn our oath Justice is a funny thing
for the poor it's what keeps them alive
and starving depending on how the local
Lord feels about his Woods his streams
his crops for the rich Justice is what
you get if you're not careful enough or
Rich enough usually how it works is you
commit a crime and the local Lord sends
his guards after you or your victim's
family family kills you and the guards
go after them instead or you do nothing
and the guards come after you anyway
either way someone is brought before the
Lord and he decides what's to be done
could be a fine if you're rich enough to
pay it otherwise it's the dungeons the
chopping block or the wall if your
family honor goes back hundreds of years
to a time when your ancestors hit other
men harder than they were hit you have
another option trial by combat you
either fight your accuser or you both
pick Champions to fight on your behalf
and the gods will favor the righteous
man as long as he's also the strongest
the quickest or the luckiest once in a
long while you may get two real Highborn
shits having a go to each other and one
of them might be full enough to demand a
trial by seven exactly how it sounds
seven men against seven men makes for a
good show I guess but any man who's been
in battle knows that the more men
involved the less skill needed the more
chance of accidents just ask that tarian
prince who got his head staved in by his
brother all those years ago and all for
some hedge night a wheel with two hubs
will not turn and a kingdom with two
kings will burn as the saying goes not
that such a cost ever stopped anyone
with even the remotest claim and
opportunity much less House of black
fire their rebellions consumed tens of
years and thousands of lives first
Damon's own then his son Damon II who
reigned for a night then another son
hagon crowned by bittersteel another
legitimized great bastard who had
founded the golden company to support
the Blackfire claim when haon was
executed bitter steel crowned hagon's
eldest son Damon III who in turn was
slain by their lord commander of the
King's Guard s Duncan the tall the war
of the nine peny Kings they called it
but I never saw a king or earned a penny
after the war ended I heard it all
started when an exiled Royal bastard
raised an army of cell swords and the
rightful King sent his own Army to stop
an invasion sounds simple the way the
maesters tell it but an army isn't like
a dog that comes when you whistle the
king calls on great Lords who call on
lesser Lords who send out their captives
to round up all the peasant men on the
land the Lord claims to own if the Lord
is wise and generous his new soldiers
are given steel swords and wooden
Shields to fight his battles most of our
army fought with sharp
sticks singers still sing of the Valiant
Heroes made in the War Sir Brendan Tully
the Blackfish sir Tywin Lannister and
Prince Aries Targaryen sir barriston
seli the Bold who slew the bastard
Pretender and ended the war at a stroke
but the king whose Crown we were
defending never came he mattered too
much I suppose his hand commanded the
Crown's armies and died valiantly in his
son's arms
or so the singers say I never saw that
either I did see the soldiers when they
came to our village they declared I was
too young to F but my brothers and
friends were all going and I wouldn't be
left behind my oldest brother said I
could be his Squire though he wasn't a
knight just a pop boy armed with a
stolen kitchen knife he'd never need it
I saw him collapse on the march from
fever along with many from our village I
saw our shoes fall apart on the road our
clothes rot off our bodies and half of
us our beds from the sickness
and fear and then we got to the wall in
the step Stones I saw a mace cave in my
last brother's head I saw the Lord who
led us there cut down and some other
Lords shout that we were his now one day
I looked around and realized all my
friends and Kim were gone that was
fighting beside strangers under a banner
I'd never seen didn't know where I was
or how to get home when a lord rode up
shouting at us to form ranks with our
size and hoes I couldn't remember which
side I was on then the knights came down
on us spaceless men all in steel and the
Thunder of their charge filled the world
I closed my
eyes years later after the war had faded
into songs I opened them again and saw
what I had done and what I had become in
the war and
since I went looking for a way back
home I know I'll never reach it but that
doesn't mean I don't need a guide
according to Legend House Targaryen
survived the Doom of valyria thanks to
danies the dreamer who forsaw the
Calamity and convinced her father to
flee their Homeland it could be true the
targaryens were always a bit more but as
ma yendle points out in the East the
targaryens were one of a thousand minor
noble families and in Westeros they
became Kings politics not prophecy could
have drawn them to our
Shores politics can also explain the
Prophecies of Damon Blackfire II a
Targaryen bastard rumored to possess the
family gift while posing as a hedge
Knight he told a future Lord commander
of the King's Guard that he dreamt of a
dragon hatching at White Wall's castle
and took it as a sign that he'd win the
Iron
Throne perhaps if he'd slept a bit
longer he'd have dreamt of the king's
hand putting down his Rebellion a day
later before it even began
most maesters dismiss all targaryan
claims of Prophecy as Mystic nonsense a
relic of their Eastern
ancestry to be fair across the narrow
sea there isn't a market without a
warlock from celling fortunes or a
shadow binder from a Shai reading Fates
in
blood or so I hear from the
maesters the tarians never stopped
trying to revive their dragons Aryan
bright Flame drank a draft of wildfire
and burned to death Aon V 5 tried to
hatch Stone dragon eggs with sorcery and
burned to
death Sam said you wanted to see me who
are
you my
father was
Micah the first of his
name my brother Egan reigned after him
when I had refused the
throne what you telling him now only
what the little Lord wants to hear get
your supper I want some time with
him
mother's looking for
you
[Music]
hey